the United States gave Russia and
ultimatum if we didn't stop developing
this missile then Washington would
consider the INF treaty over today that
deadline ran out there are no new US
missiles no new NATO missiles in Europe
but there are more and more new Russian
missiles so to offer a moratorium is
without any credibility what they could
have done and what they should have done
was to respect the NF Treaty the Russian
missile violates the terms of the treaty
it can carry a nuclear warhead it's
mobile hard to detect and it puts
European capitals in range and at risk
in an interview with Sky News Russia's
Deputy Foreign Minister blamed NATO for
this situation Secretary General of NATO
mr. Stoltenberg and what individual
countries said that there are no actual
plans or intentions to deploy
nuclear-armed intermediate-range
missiles but for us an eventual
deployment of conventionally armed
missiles will be equally disabled izing
because number one as you exactly
rightly said there is no trust there is
no confidence Russia doesn't believe
NATO in the 1980s the opposition to
nuclear war became a social movement as
the world lived under the threat of two
superpowers squaring up to each other
Greenham common became the focus of
protests against American missiles in
the UK but there was concern both sides
of the Iron Curtain and then in 1987 the
INF treaty was signed by Ronald Reagan
and Mikhail Gorbachev it banned missiles
with ranges between 400 and 4,300 miles
there by taking Europe out of Moscow's
firing line and in turn preventing the
u.s. from stationing weapons on the
continent it has remained the bedrock of
nuclear stability ever since until now
regardless of what transpires the
parties should avoid destabilizing
developments and urgently seek agreement
on a new common paths for international
arms control and I strongly encourage
the United States and the Russian
Federation to extend the so call
new start agreement to provide stability
and the time to negotiate future arms
controls measures this is a serious
moment for the world
it doesn't mean a nuclear war is likely
but it could be the start of a new arms
race Russia and America both again led
by strongmen and once more building up
their Arsenal's alistair bug will sky
news